as people try to recover from the impact
of cyclone Freddy they also have to bury
the dead
and as the rain continues here in the
village of tautira they have to scoop
water out of grave pits before laying
the victims to rest more than 320 people
have now been confirmed dead
and thousands more missing after the
Cyclone tore through southern Africa for
a second time in weeks outside Malawi's
commercial Capital blantire people in
this Village have been cut off from
their neighbors as roads and bridges lay
in ruin
president Lazarus chaquerres appealed to
International assistance
while his government's been criticized
for not doing enough
the main challenge is not government
failing to respond it is the
inaccessibility of some of these camps
because Bridges have been washed off and
roads have been cut and you know so that
people cannot travel to where they are
so there is help that is already on hand
it cannot get to the people because of
challenges of accessibility in some
parts there's no electricity or running
water we have people who are who have
been rendered homeless they don't have
food they don't have clothing they don't
have water clean water so it's really
bad we we we don't even know what people
are going to eat for lunch this today or
even supper we don't know because we
have not yet received any relief item as
we speak
across the country more than 88 000
people have been displaced
with many Sheltering in temporary camps
more rain is expected in the next few
days
raising fears of flash floods and more
destruction